- So wait, you co-hosted Access Hollywood
with your husband Crowley recently.
So how did that go? Was
it fun or terrifying?
- First of all. There he is.
So Crowley Sullivan, my
husband, he was so funny, y'all,
because I've been on
this show for 12 years.
We talked about this
to get hired at age 40.
And I'll be 52 this year.
- Yeah.
- So he sits down and he is like, oh
so this is what you've
been doing with your time!
Like nobody in my family cares.
- They don't watch it?
- They don't watch, they
don't know what I do,
you know what I mean?
- I love that. That's kinda nice.
- I love it.
- Yeah. Cause
- We've made sure the kids are the stars.
They it's all about them.
And I remember once I was
covering the Golden Globes
and I was sort of feeling
myself, cause I had these lashes
and my fake hair and
come like coming home.
- You're like just so wonderful.
- Oh! And quickly side
note, that was the day
that I got Brad Pitt, y'all.
I'm walking on the red carpet.
I bump into Brad Pitt. I panic.
And I say to him, Hey Brad, Kit Pitt.
And I'm like I'm not Kit Pitt.
And he says, Maiden or Merry?
And I was like, oh my God,
he's talking back, Brad.
I said Maiden. And he goes,
there's not many of us in there.
And he starts talking to me.
Then I say, I love architecture. And then
- (Laughing) architecture
- And then they pull him away. But anyway.
So I had a big moment.
- I love your random things, Kit Pitt
and I love architecture.
- Exactly. Cause apparently,
I read an article
that he likes architecture.
It went south quickly, but I
get home and I'm feeling myself
and I'm in my dress and
literally the whole family's
like mom, what's for dinner?
Like, you know, you gonna
make your Parma Rosa.
And like, I couldn't
have loved it anymore.
Like nobody really cares about my day job.
- I love that.
- Yeah.
- My kids look at me,
cause I don't wear hair
or make up like if I'm not working.
I have to be paid to do this.
- Yes.
- And I literally, cause
I'm allergic as well,
so it stinks, the eye make up and it.
I love you Glow. My
makeup artist and stuff.
But I, when I get home, my
son, especially he freaks out.
He's like, can you take a shower?
- Yeah.
- Cause it freaks him out.
Cause he's like, I don't like you in that.
He's like, I like you. And
I'm that's so nice, thank you.
- I know, my kids are like that.
My husband's the opposite.
Cause on the weekend I'm
baseball hat, no make up.
He's like, where's that
Monday to Friday lady?
- This is false advertising.
- Exactly.
Cause that lady with the
lashes ever come home
and I'm like beat with my hat.
- Yeah. You're like, no, you're lucky.